just because your baby rejects a certain
food don't give up that's how you
immediately end any opportunity of them
ever learning to like it yeah you just
keep offering it over and over again
it's so easy as a parent to be like well
yeah why am I going to make food that I
know my kid might not like and I think
that tends to be such a sort of common
barrier but the reality is is that kids
are picky and so if we sort of stop it
and don't give it then we're really not
giving our kids the opportunity to be
adventurous eaters yeah the beauty of
baby LED weaning is that you can really
look at okay what am I making already
for the family and how can I adapt a
portion for a baby and I think that's
why Beyblade we need does resonate with
so many people can you imagine like baby
number five you're having a spoon feed
at dinner it just wouldn't happen
because this is this window of
opportunity for flavor acceptance we
want you doing everything we want you
trying a new food every day the old
advice that you had to do one food every
three to five days it actually just
doesn't really make sense it's not
necessary and it could also inhibit this
ability
exposure to a wide variety of foods
pretty quickly so yeah fruits vegetables
all of the foods your family eats if you
can find a way to prepare them in a baby
safe form two purposes of solid
introduction before age one is to really
ensure adequate iron intake and then
also promote adventurous eating your
baby loves food they start to you know
usually accept a lot of different
flavors and we really want to sort of
capture that
in this follow-up episode with two
dietitians Whitney and Alex from
plant-based Juniors we sit down to
discuss postpartum care and optimal
nutrition for mothers during the
postpartum phase and a dive into
starting baby on solid foods I
personally loved this conversation
because I'm super passionate about
breastfeeding and supporting mothers and
they're sensitive and delicate
postpartum experience I also just love
the information Whitney and Alex have to
share on optimal nutrition for babies
and mothers both mothers who
predominantly plant-based children
themselves plant-based Juniors was
created because they saw a need for easy
to access information on evidence-based
nutrition for pregnancy and kids they've
since helped families all around the
world to feel confident and empowered in
nourishing their families with plants as
the primary focus in this episode we
cover nutrition considerations for
postpartum mothers and throughout the
breastfeeding Journey tips for
successful breastfeeding what the
science says about raising children
plant-based baby-led weaning starting
baby unsolid foods picky eating food
play food exposure and more I hope you
enjoy our conversation and welcome to
the Ellen Fisher podcast here we go
foreign
if you've been needing to upgrade your
cleaning routine I've got the perfect
non-toxic and biodegradable cleaning
products for you to try Branch Basics is
free of fragrances hormone disruptors
and harmful preservatives that replace
all your toxic cleaning products I feel
comfortable and safe using them in my
home around my children and they're also
plant-based which is super important to
me so many of the cleaning products on
the market are largely filled with water
wasting plastic and creating unnecessary
waste but Branch Basics has a solution a
concentrate that is used in different
dilutions to create all of the cleaning
solutions then just refill the bottles
when you're out it's simple and
environmentally friendly one bottle of
concentrate makes three all-purpose
cleaners three bathroom cleaners three
streak free cleaners three Foaming Hand
washes and 64 loads of laundry because
you dilute the concentrate with water in
the reusable bottles and the oxygen
boost is a multi-use powder that can be
used for a variety of different purposes
such as removing stains and laundry to
deodorizing whitening and brightening
clothing and in bathrooms for grout
shower and toilets these products work
amazing too no need for toxic cleaning
products it's time to replace all your
toxic cleaning products because Branch
basic sets you up for success with their
starter kit which comes with both the
concentrate and the oxygen boost so use
my code ln15 for 15 all Branch basic
starter kits you'll be so happy with the
result and making the switch to
non-toxic and sustainable cleaning
products they're effective beautiful
bottles in your home and it's just a
win-win solution all right we are back
for another episode I'm having so much
fun with you guys I feel like there
would be no lag in talking with us like
there hasn't been a moment yes
what do we talk about next there hasn't
been a moment of that at all in our
Kindred Spirits yeah I really feel that
way I feel like we can go on and on and
on together and we haven't even talked
about so many things that we could talk
about but today we're going to talk
about postpartum care for mothers
um considerations for breastfeeding to
be successful at breastfeeding and a
deeper dive into starting solid foods
which we touched on the breastfeeding
and solid foods or I did with Dr Gemma
Newman but we're going to take a little
deeper dive in that one and just hone in
on that specific the specifics of that
so before we get into this if you
haven't listened to the first episode
that we did with you two Whitney and
Alex from plant-based Juniors definitely
go check out that first one it was an
amazing episode
um and maybe you could just quickly just
share a little bit about you guys real
quick for those who haven't listed the
first one sure we are Whitney and Alex
we're both registered dietitian
nutritionists moms of two kids each and
we are the co-creators of plant-based
Juniors a platform dedicated to helping
parents and also other professionals get
more plants on the plate and understand
all of the various aspects of both
plant-based and predominantly
plant-based eating patterns yeah and our
our goal is really to be as inclusive as
a community as possible we focus on
really bringing everyone in to consume
more plants more often and we do this
through our books and our courses
Perfect all right let's jump right into
it what are the most important nutrition
considerations for breastfeeding mothers
and the postpartum experience to to like
be well nourished in your postpartum
phase especially because it can be a
stressful time with having a new baby
especially if it's your first time when
you're just trying to figure it out and
you're like why is my baby crying or how
do I do this breastfeeding thing and
support myself yeah at the same time
professionally yeah how do you you know
best set yourself up for success to feel
your best and take care of yourself and
your baby yeah I mean the the nutrient
considerations for breastfeeding are
really the same as pregnancy just
increased uh we want to be able to make
sure that we are nourishing mom that we
are aiding in her recovery after giving
birth and then also providing enough
nutrition to pass to her breast milk in
order to nourish her baby because we
gotta uh help Mama heal and we also have
to grow that sweet little baby so uh you
know the big thing to consider is
calories this is really a time to focus
on nourishment and not on weight loss
that's also going to help you set up for
a really successful breastfeeding
Journey because one of the biggest
factors when it comes to having an
adequate milk supply is ensuring that
there is enough energy enough calories
to do so protein needs stay about the
same uh and then you know just sort of
again the the similar considerations
that we'd focus on when it comes to
pregnancy
um ACOG does recommend DHA as well if
you're not consuming fatty fish two
times a week about 300 milligrams uh a
day and then again ensuring adequate
intake of B12 vitamin D iodine vitamin A
Sort of all of the all of the many
nutrients and a lot of women want to
continue taking their prenatal vitamin
which is which is fine as well yeah the
kind of reassuring thing or relief I
think is that you don't have to learn a
whole new set of nutritional knowledge a
lot of the things that you did or pretty
much everything you did in pregnancy
just kind of keep doing you just need a
little bit more of most of the nutrients
so keep taking your prenatal vitamin
keep nourishing your body with all of
the foods that we talked about the only
nutrient need that actually goes down
during breastfeeding is iron and that's
because when you're breastfeeding you're
not menstruating you're not growing the
baby anymore so you don't need to
provide iron for the growing baby and
breast milk is actually really low in
iron too so you're not trying to get
iron to be transferred through the
breast milk so provided you didn't have
some trauma during birth and lose a lot
of blood you actually don't need as much
iron and that doesn't mean don't stop
eating iron-rich foods you certainly
should continue those but if you were
perhaps taking an additional iron
supplement because
um you were worried you weren't getting
enough through your prenatal you could
probably discontinue that during the
breastfeeding period interesting that's
really interesting about iron yeah
you're I think your needs are actually
are they the same as an adult male or
around that yeah so males have like such
a low irony there's RDA is eight
milligrams for a man whereas it's 18 for
a woman and then all the way up to 27
milligrams for a pregnant woman so this
is like the only time during a woman's
life that it like plummets down to that
really low level that's really
interesting yeah and I love what you
brought up about focusing on nourishment
and increasing your calories rather than
weight loss us it's not the time to be
thinking about weight loss it's the last
thing that should be on your mind that
weight is like supposed to be there you
you grew life and your body was so
incredible to be able to nourish not
only your pregnancy but also to be
strong enough to deliver that baby you
know we don't suddenly need to now be
focused on weight loss and that's when
we really do see a lot of problems with
supplies when women all of a sudden uh
understandably thanks to societal
pressure feel like all of a sudden they
need to bounce back or whatever and they
start restricting calories dipping too
low and their body just doesn't have
enough energy to produce enough breast
milk and hopefully this comes with women
feeling supported that's right after
they give birth to because when it comes
to eating enough calories you really
need a lot of support yeah because you
have to be resting and healing in bed so
what recommendation do you have for that
there yeah I mean I I would say the
first thing just sort of first and
foremost is giving yourself that Grace
and also to you know really sort of take
advantage of whatever Village you have
um you know I used to tell my friends
like I I don't need anything that baby
doesn't need anything but we need food
uh and so you know I I don't want baby
clothes but I do want you to come over
with some energy balls or you know
something because that's just so helpful
um thankfully you know with with both my
pregnancies my husband was a really
great support to help you know make food
and have things ready to supply so I
would just say lean wherever you can but
then also give yourself Grace you know
there was definitely many times where my
meals and snacks would be just a quick
piece of bread with some peanut butter
on it or even like a bowl of cereal just
some sort of a quick nourishment didn't
always have to be this
um you know beautiful abundant meal yeah
my first Midwife had told me after I
gave birth she said nobody should coming
should be coming to your home unless
they're bringing you food or doing your
laundry
this isn't for them to you know just
love on your baby this is the time for
you to love on your baby and bond with
your baby everyone else is supposed to
be taking care of you now I know that
that's not really the case for a lot of
women or for some women where they don't
maybe have the support system that would
be optimal or ideal but like you said
lean in wherever you can and don't be
afraid to ask for help yeah and I think
so one of us are not conditioned to to
ask for help yeah we're so used to being
Superwoman and just saying like I've got
it I'm okay and I feel like it is such a
great time to be like actually no here's
what I need and here's exactly how you
can help and you know I think all of us
know when we have someone that we love
who you know just had a baby we want to
to help them where we can and so you
know it's it's very like okay great this
is exactly what I can do I know this is
going to help you and not take away from
your experience yeah yeah our PBJ energy
balls are like the number one gift I
give to people who just gave birth I'm
like here is a frozen badge you put it
in your freezer hopefully that'll last
you here a little while and a lot of
times people are well-meaning and they
want to help but if they can say
something if they say something open
ended like hey let me know if you need
any help it's on like it's less likely
the person's gonna take you up on their
offer unless you get something specific
so something that can make it easy for
you if you're the person that people are
offering help to is in the postpartum
phase you can send them a meal train
link hopefully you can have that yeah
yeah hopefully you can have one of your
friends set that up for you and then
send it out to all your friends but if
anybody's asking how can I help in some
way like send them the meal train link
and you can even put in dietary
preferences in that link so that people
know you could even put links to recipes
you like any of that stuff so make it
easy for people to know like how to help
you your best yeah so smart Yeah so
basically it sounds like you just need
to increase your calories in regards to
nutrition yeah we're already focusing on
the nutrition and if you're eating a
quality nutrient dense diet by
increasing your calories your by proxy
also going to be increasing all of those
micronutrients and protein and
everything as well yeah so it like we
said in the last episode it doesn't have
to be this quantitative thing it's kind
of trusting your body eating when when
you feel like you need it which is all
the time when you're breastfeeding yeah
eating lots of frequent meals because
sometimes you don't know how long it's
going to be before you're going to get
another one so if you have an
opportunity yes and larger portions like
don't be afraid of the large portions
because you need your calories your
caloric needs are increasing yes you
said so just eat more eat more bites eat
bigger bigger smoothies bigger bowls of
you know beans and rice and potatoes
with hummus or guacamole all the normal
wonderful healthy foods just increase
that plate a little bit more and don't
be afraid to eat until you're totally
satisfied yes and I think the main way
to do that is really then working on the
mental aspect of letting go of all of
these preconceived notions of how you're
supposed to be postpartum how quickly
you're supposed to lose this weight if
you can let that go and trust your body
on how much you need to nourish yourself
that's going to be so much better I so
many women I talk about like I was so
hungry I wanted to eat in the middle of
the night when I breastfeed I'm like
then eat yeah they're like butt
intermittent fasting and this and that
and you're like all of that needs to go
out the window yeah I mean I think every
single night and with both of my
children and probably the first six
months I would have a pita with peanut
butter in the middle of the night
because that's what I was craving yeah 3
A.M I like I'm getting I like there's no
reason why I wouldn't nourish myself
right now totally and on my main YouTube
channel I'll I always like show a week
in my week like after with a newborn
baby and I'm showing how large my
portions are like it hasn't premium this
giant bowl of you know all my favorite
type of fixings and I'm eating bigger
bigger portions than I'm used to because
like you said now is not the time to
focus on weight loss and the weight the
your optimal weight will happen very
naturally and gradually the way it's
supposed to when you're eating a
well-planned healthy diet yeah normalize
nutrition and nourishment yes yeah and
then just last thing I'll say is I think
this is also a great way that the
partner can feel involved you know
especially when it comes to
breastfeeding I feel like so much of it
is about mama and baby and it's like you
you know your partner can be supportive
of you to say like okay you know in the
it's the middle of the night feed
obviously they're not going to be able
to help you with the breastfeeding part
this is when I would tell my husband
like I need water and a snack and like
that's how he can help me be nourished
and and help me in this breastfeeding
journey and also like some feel like
part of the team together because I feel
like sometimes dads do feel like they
want to be part of this like feeding
journey and they just aren't capable of
doing it but allowing them to help with
some of those tasks makes it feel like
you guys really are sort of on this
family unit together absolutely that's
so well said because they feel so good
when they can feel like they're helping
you they just wanna they see you and
they're like I just want to help you I
want to be there for you but I can't
like feed the baby yeah what can I do
and that that goes with food but it can
also go with nighttime diaper changes
that's right while you're laying in bed
and resting like all that combined
letting him help you because I think
sometimes women can be a little bit like
no I need to do it I'm the baby's mom
and so I need to take care of everything
but let your partner have one help you
and they want to you know for the vast
majority they want to be involved it's
it's their child too and they want to
feel connected yeah and if they don't
want to have them listen to this episode
have a talk yeah so how does nutrition
play a role in successful breastfeeding
like we said you know making sure that
you're properly nourished is going to
make sure that you have enough energy
um physically and emotionally to carry
out the breastfeeding Journey so it's
recommended that women don't dip below
1800 calories per day but again if
you're doing all the things that we
talked about that won't be happening if
you're focusing on nourishment versus
some sort of body goal that you think
you're trying to get to that's the most
important thing hydration plays a
massive role obviously you're producing
a lot of liquid you need to be taking in
um enough enough liquid breastfeeding
moms need about 16 cups of fluid a day
but that doesn't have to just come from
water can also come from tea it can come
from any other beverage that you're
consuming even coffee counts towards you
really interesting yeah so this is a
very common myth is that coffee and tea
and other things with caffeine actually
be are diuretics and therefore they take
away from the recommended amount of
fluid that you're supposed to have for
per day and this applies to both women
breastfeeding as well as anyone you know
the eight cups a day that liquid
actually does count towards towards
these things because it's not such a big
diuretic that it outweighs the fluid
balance of what you're taking in so you
can certainly count your your water your
tea your coffee whatever you're drinking
your smoothies all the foods you're
consuming that are rich in water I think
you guys have a lot of very water packed
tropical fruits here
um so just making sure you're getting
enough I like always had my stainless
steel water bottle on hand and I
specifically bought one with a handle on
it so that I could be carrying the
millions of things that have been
feeding moms carrying yeah you
additional to the baby I also like
coconut water even if you can't get
fresh coat of water even bottle coconut
water like it's such a hydrating yes
always makes me feel so good postpartum
yes and you're getting a little bit of
energy in there too yeah that's
definitely the electrolytes yes yes
totally and you know the the biggest
thing too I just want to say when it
comes to ensuring you have an adequate
Supply besides adequate calories and
hydration is supply and demand you know
especially those first few days when
baby is cluster feeding feed constantly
that's going to help to you know
establish your supply uh really feeding
on demand if you're having any Supply
concerns whether real or you know
perceived we would definitely recommend
working with a lactation consultant and
ibclc as soon as possible they can help
identify any latch issues if there's any
pain involved because really the earlier
that you see guidance and that you seek
support and help the likelier that you
are going to continue having a healthy
frustrating relationship yes that's in
the we talk a lot about that in my
breastfeeding ebook with an ivclc
Natalie Marcus and we talk about the
importance of hiring a lactation
consultant within the first few days
after giving birth especially if it's
your first time yeah you know if it's
not if this is not your first like Rodeo
you know what I mean like it is totally
come supernaturally after the first time
you know but the first time it is a
learned experience so to help lower the
stress like let someone help you hire
somebody it is so worth the 150 bucks
yeah I think I've heard you say before
is that we kind of believe that it's
supposed to be this innate ability that
we just do and it happens perfectly and
that's just not actually the way it is
that's not how it's been through the
course of history so acknowledging that
it's going to be challenging and it's
something you have to learn yeah I did
kind of naively think oh I'll just
figure it out like the same I'm
Supernatural like not Supernatural I'm
super into natural living not
Supernatural yeah yeah
birth I'm like oh my gosh I have no idea
what I'm I'm doing I was calling my
Midwife in the middle of the night
crying because I couldn't figure it out
like he's not latching and all I don't
know what I'm doing and it really just
came down to the mechanics like being
taught how to do it my Midwife would say
take a deep breath yeah yeah calm drink
some water go wake up the husband go
wake up Andrew hand the baby to your
husband go to the bathroom take a break
take a break let your partner like help
you with the baby so you can have a
moment to yourself and then come back at
it you know and learn the mechanics of
it and having a lactation consultant can
help you with that and ease a lot of
that stress yeah it should be mandated
for for every woman and unfortunately
it's not yeah it should be it should be
like supportive yeah it should be part
of like postpartum care you know
wherever you are you should be able to
have access to a free ibclc because we
know just societal benefits too of
breastfeeding but that's a whole other
tangent yeah right totally but there is
something to be said like you said about
in the past there's always like a
well-seasoned mother someone in our
village what they were doing yeah in the
village to like show a woman how to
breastfeed it's not something that just
comes natural like you think it would
yeah but then once you do figure it out
you're like oh this really is like like
second like you know it look at the back
of your hands now it's super easy so is
there anything else in regards to
breastfeeding support that can optimize
the health of your baby and the health
of yourself while you're breastfeeding
nutrition wise yeah the only other thing
I would say is that uh the AAP
recommends that all exclusively
breastfed infants
um have vitamin D
um breast milk is naturally very low in
vitamin D
um likely because we probably were
exposing our babies to lots of adequate
Sunshine once upon a time but
considering the way that most of us live
we want to ensure that baby gets vitamin
D in the diet and you can just get a
supplement put it right into baby's
mouth or even put it on your nipple let
them suck it off so is that something
you recommend for every baby
every baby that's uh exclusively or
partially breastfed oh interesting
because vitamin like I said vitamin D is
naturally low there is some research
showing that moms supplementing with
very high doses like 6400 IUS of vitamin
D could then produce enough vitamin D
through their breast milk to meet the
needs of a child
um but it kind of seems to lead to us to
do that in order to transfer it also it
reaches the upper tolerable level for
breastfeeding moms so just simply
providing your baby with it's like one
drop interesting vitamin D what about
like for because my tendency like I said
is like we do have we do take
supplements we're not like anti-supples
but there's we're just very specific
about which ones and I'd rather get my
nutrition and the the needs met through
natural ways when I can so when it comes
to like vitamin D for us we live in a
climate where we can get enough Sun so
we're we have always had the approach of
very small amount
ounce of healthy sun exposure for our
children and with babies it starts at
very small amounts and so it'll be you
know this was even my midwives would
recommend this like you know just go
outside for five minutes naked with your
baby let your baby be naked in the Sun
at like healthy times in the Sun and let
them get adjusted to little bits of sun
and that that will prevent jaundice and
be good for their vitamin D levels and
so just increasing that little bit so
you don't do you feel like that's not
enough like again from an evolutionary
perspective that is how babies got their
vitamin D
um and it could work for someone who
definitely has consistent uh sun
exposure at a specific latitude whose
light pigmentation because all of these
things affect our body's ability to
synthesize vitamin D in the skin
um I think the problem is I'm not saying
what you did was wrong it obviously
worked out I think you know your kids
how adequate vitamin D levels but
um there's no guidelines so we don't
have anything to follow to say well if
you're a white baby and you live at this
latitude yeah yeah five minutes of sun
and if you are a black baby and you live
at this latitude you're gonna need this
much yeah
um so the safest most responsible way
would just be and the way that's
actually going to work for most people
because there are just so many factors
that impair our body's ability to
synthesize no it makes perfect sense it
makes sense like why you guys yeah
advocate for what you do and you're
doing the most evidence the most like
easy to understand and straightforward
for the masses right yeah when it comes
to like specific situations like you
said or someone who lives in the tropics
and we're very careful and very aware of
healthy sun exposure to me that's what
makes the most sense for us and it just
depends on the family yeah well and
that's what Universal recommendations
and guidelines are for it's really to
help meet sort of this low lowest common
denominator in a sense right so it's not
saying that this is the only thing
that's going to work for every single
person it's saying okay when we look at
trends when we look at you know current
intake levels when we look at uh
concerns Public Health you know what's
what's happening we need to be able to
make Universal guidelines and you know
for the most part too these are really
easy to pass on sometimes when the
recommendations become too nuanced then
it can lose sort of its Effectiveness
because if it's like oh but for this
situation it's this for this situation
it's this if someone's not getting
regular prenatal care or is not being
exposed to some of these you know
education messages it can just feel like
I'm really confused I'm not sure so if
we just sort of say like okay this is
the recommendation full stop there's no
harm in in supplementing if you get also
vitamin D from the sun because you're
not getting anywhere close to that
excessive upper limit uh when it comes
to babies and it's probably going to be
protective for most individuals yeah
it's easier for people to understand and
know exactly what to do and there's no
question yes yeah right makes perfect
sense and the cost benefit like we know
with inadequate vitamin D the dangers
are so high the the result could be
rickets you know where they're not
properly forming bones and stuff so yeah
that's not something I worry about for
my family yeah
yeah yeah yeah yes absolutely but no
that's great that's really important
information I'm glad you brought up the
vitamin D at Factor because it's all
super important and most people are
living inside all day even us in the
tropics we're probably not outside as we
probably should be so that just shows
about how much people who aren't even in
place with good sun exposure are not
getting enough fight well and time of
the year you know like I had my baby in
March which is still too cold uh in my
opinion in in St Louis and like yeah
when I took her outside you know we
would do a lot of daily walks but she
was bundled you know it was 30 degrees
Yeah you know and I was you know
protecting her her beautiful delicate
skin so even if you are outside it
depends on time of year and also where
you're living all right let's talk about
starting maybe on solid foods this is
something you guys are really passionate
about you share a lot on plant-based
Juniors anybody listening or watching
definitely go follow plant-based Studios
on Instagram because we share so much
information and food tips for raising
healthy kids and toddlers and babies so
what's your philosophy on starting maybe
on solid foods yeah you know really the
the big reason that plant-based Juniors
came to be was because of this topic
around starting solids because we were
both so frustrated with what we felt
like was common sort of nutrition
recommendations this you know hyper
focus on beef being a first food is that
really a thing especially lately there's
been a big push um
in the past few years has put a lot of
money behind campaigning different
organizations in the U.S to position I
always thought the perfect first food
wow that's so interesting yeah I always
thought it was like everyone's saying
the pureed peas and the carrots and it's
like they're really not talking about
beef that was probably even older like
you know when purees came first came on
the market yeah I'd say in like the past
five maybe a little bit longer years the
thief Council and and listen you know we
we can't deny that beef is an excellent
source of iron of you know certain
nutrients that we would want to ensure
um are are given to infancy but anyways
so we were so frustrated by those
messages and I was like well I haven't
eaten meat since 2006. I'm definitely
not going to start feeding my baby meat
um and I felt like the the messages that
were out there that were counter to that
we both felt like weren't
um strong enough or also weren't really
being presented by health professionals
so that's really one of the big reasons
that we wanted to start plant-based
Juniors was to help fellow families who
wanted to sort of say wait a minute I
don't want to feed my child B for liver
or some of these sort of you know
recommendations that are out there
sometimes what do I do if I want to feed
my baby plants yeah and what is what are
the downsides to yes it's excellent
sources of certain things like iron like
you said but what are the downsides to
introducing beef as a first food well
there's no literature specifically about
like beef consumption in early age but I
think it's the same thing as with a lot
of studies that haven't been
specifically on kids but like the
long-term implications of these dietary
patterns so I mean we know that foods
that are high in saturated fat and we
know actually red meat and processed
Meats themselves are all things that
later in life are associated with poor
health more increased risk of chronic
diseases so twofold it's likely that an
excessive consumption during childhood
could start to set the stage for some of
these conditions later but also we know
that this early feeding period is when
kids really develop their flavor
preferences they start to establish the
foods that they like and that they're
going to eat later in life so whether or
not even these Foods may cause problems
in that time period if these become
preferred Foods then later in life
that's going to be their preferred foods
and we definitely know later in life
that these foods are associated with um
for health yeah absolutely those first
few years are so crucial in setting kids
palettes up for success to love fruits
and vegetables and to eat them in
abundance yeah yeah and there's so many
other sources like of the same nutrients
that you get in beef we can get in other
plant-based foods that then come
packaged with even more beneficial
nutrients like fiber and other vitamins
and minerals right wasn't there a study
they did the autopsies on like uh in a
war or something and they found our
Solosis there's big studies both on like
children who died unexpectedly whether
in car crashes and then like you said
there was young
um men coming back from from the war I
want to say Korean War yeah okay
um and yeah showing that there was
already arterial blockages developing
meaning that atherosclerosis does start
to develop early in childhood
interesting and what's linked with
atherosclerosis increased intake of
saturated fats for one absolutely okay
yeah so let's get into specifically how
to start baby on solid foods what's the
recommendation there yeah so uh the the
type of feeding there's there's not
really a best feeding approach as far as
the literature is concerned there's
really sort of two approaches that are
typically presented one would be like a
traditional pureed approach which is you
know spoon feeding baby pureed food and
the other is sort of a more oh it's a
recent coined approach and that would be
baby LED weaning or self-feeding which
is really allowing baby to self-feed
right from the beginning we definitely
need more research uh on baby lead
weaning but sort of the the emerging
evidence is that it may help baby uh
self-regulate which just sort of is a is
a way to say that allowing baby to
really understand sort of these innate
hungerfulness cues right from the
beginning of starting solid foods which
may help when it comes to Weight
Management later in life and then also
you know because baby is introduced to
such a wide variety of textures right
from the beginning and then also usually
a wider variety of flavors that may help
sort of that earlier introduction to to
reduce picky eating later now so what do
you think needs more research on because
to me the baby LED weaning makes so much
more sense than pureed foods for a lot
of different reasons yeah like you said
the pureed Foods having the inability to
like know when you're done and letting
babies pick Foods up themselves and
stuff when they're done helps with all
sorts of things like their hand eye
coordination picking up foods that they
want the autonomy aspect and stopping
when they're done but also like the
chewing factor and how important it is
for their jaw development to be chewing
Foods at a young age as opposed to
pureed foods which just sets them up for
not wanting to chew because our we can
get really used to like having soft
foods and that would not wanting to have
to work for chewing and how important
that is so what kind of research do you
need do you need to see to feel
confident that maybe baby LED weeding is
better than period Foods we definitely
are major advocates for baby leading
Alex wanted to do it from the start did
it with both kids I'm so excited what's
preaching to me about it I'm all excited
about it I did it with my kids
um I think what she was saying in
regards to saying that there are proven
benefits that's what we need the
research for there hasn't been a lot of
studies right to say like yes kids who
were baby LED
kids who self-fed as babies do have a
better sense of their own hunger and
fullness cues like we don't have that
right research we have all of these uh
theoretical beliefs about the benefits
that we think are derived from them yeah
that makes sense
um and so yeah hopefully research will
eventually prove that out but like you
said it in in the whole point of baby
Little Wayne and it's kind of like a
return to the way children have been fed
for since the beginning of people yeah
um so I think what we try to say is like
when we say one isn't better than the
other I think what we mean more is that
there are many different ways to feed a
baby and it doesn't have to be so black
and white I think there's become these
like two camps where it's like babies
can only self-feed and you can't feed
them anything that's even of a pure
texture and if you even put a spoon near
their mouth you're a horrible parent
yeah yeah
you know so many things happen through
the course of history pre-mat
pre-mastication was really how babies
were originally Fed so they were eating
softer Foods or anything parents
probably chewed up and like spit into
their mouths
um actually
I remember like long before I had kids
hearing about that I was like oh my God
that's crazy okay and I heard that and I
was like I can't wait to baby bird oh my
gosh that's hilarious did you guys see
that I had her on the podcast yeah and
she's so fun and hilarious and how she
always is all about the natural mom yeah
right and she was right that's the one I
know people did but then the media just
like loves because people just the media
likes clicks and it's easy and she's
like you know just always just the way
that she talks it's amazing and she's
just being super honest and loving and I
just love her so yeah yeah beautiful
energy she's actually one of the I think
she was the first like cool vegan book
yeah like one of the first oh I loved
her book yeah I loved it yes I tell her
all the time I'm like I love her recipes
we love you Alicia
solely feeding baby purees again we
don't have the research to say all of
those negative things potentially could
happen but it makes sense that if
especially if Furies are carry done too
long and solid and more of the handheld
and the different textures aren't
introduced early enough that is when you
might start to see some problems with
oral motor skills um so yeah no and we
kind of advocate like yeah it makes
sense you're just like trying not to be
black and white and you're just giving
what the evidence says which is what
you're doing in your job well and and
just sort of two two additional things
to consider is that really by eight nine
months babies should be self-feeding
some or all of the meals anyway so we're
really talking about a difference of
about two to three months uh depending
if you're doing a traditional uh spoon
bed approach versus Beyblade opinion
sort of right from the start and then
the last thing I'll say is you know even
if you do decide you know what spoon
feeding really works for my family I
feel like I enjoy it more than I do baby
LED weeding that doesn't mean that you
can't listen to babies cues and really
be attuned to them we would really
recommend responsive eating techniques
right from the start you know there are
lots of ways babies communicate to us
even from you know the first moments
that they're born that they're hungry
you know they can root they can turn
towards the spoon or towards the boob
the man latch uh or sort of turn away or
look away they're probably done and all
of this can be done we're talking about
spoon feeding too issue with spoon
feeding where it can become problematic
is when we're trying to just okay come
on take one more bite let's finish this
jar you want this you want this come on
you ate more yesterday I need you to eat
more today those is sort of where we get
away from this idea of baby being able
to really regulate appetite so whatever
way you're feeding to focus on
responsive feeding yeah you know so what
kind of foods do you recommend then for
the first foods to start your baby on
well this is where I will give it to the
messaging from the beef people protein
and iron people
um protein and really iron because you
are already getting a lot you're still
when you start solid it's going to be
getting the vast majority of your
calories from breast milk or formula and
that's very rich in protein and lots of
other nutrients the one thing that you
aren't getting a lot of is iron so you
really want to focus on iron rich first
foods and for a plant-based diet that
means things like soy Foods
beans and nuts and seeds inappropriate
form forms meaning not in choking
hazards not whole nuts yeah we did a lot
of homemade chickpea uh flatbreads I
could cut into strips and have baby eat
like a Saka a lot of our like red lentil
meatballs chickpea sort of like balls
you know really making beans sort of an
accessible way because unfortunately I
can't just give my baby quarter cup of
chickpeas and tell them to have at it
yeah I had to make it in
great ways and that was really one of
the things that we found in the
beginning sort of this like um we wanted
to continue to promote was there are so
many fun ways to make plant Foods
baby-led weaning accessible yeah
um and you know yeah for those who
aren't familiar perhaps with the
different stages from about six to eight
months baby only has what's called a
palm or grasp so all of the food that
they pick up it has to be able to fit in
their palm and they can only eat the top
of the food coming out so for baby lead
weaning you want everything to be kind
of in a stick form you want it about the
size of an adult Pinky and that way baby
can grab it and eat just the top they
know it's really helpful yeah I think
one of the concerns people have yeah in
a strip that's helpful because I think a
lot of concern people have they want to
go to the puree because they're a little
nervous about a baby so the period is
just safer it is how they feel and yeah
it's just one of those things that
that's really helpful information yeah
well and to prevent the choking another
major rule is that whatever you're
giving baby should be able to be smashed
between your fingers so kind of like you
could take a bean and just mash it
between your fingers that means it's
soft enough for them to mash with their
gums right and then the pincher grasp
which is where they can actually like
pick up little pieces of things that
develop somewhere between eight and ten
months so that's why Alex is talking
about kind of getting creative with all
these Bean things we're making patties
we're making strips yeah my favorite
food to start baby lead weaning with is
tofu
um like an X like a firm to an extra
firm just because you actually don't
have to do anything you just take it out
of the package you chop it into a strip
and you can literally give it my kids
loved it with like no seasoning no
flavoring yeah we have lots of recipes
where we get a lot more creative and
make it fun especially if you're gonna
but you really really simple at the
beginning yes yeah you want to keep it
simple and
um that's a great way to get the
nutrition in without feeling like oh I
have to prepare this whole special meal
well and you know especially as you tend
to have uh more and more children you
know the the beauty of baby bed weaning
is that you can really look at okay what
am I I'm making already for the family
and how can I adapt a portion for a baby
and I think that's why Beyblade weenie
does resonate with so many people I mean
can you imagine like baby number five
you're having a spoon feed at dinner it
just wouldn't happen like there there is
a benefit or making a whole separate
thing yes and then steaming it and
pureeing it and listen I know that works
for some people we hear all the time
from clients who will say things like
I'm so terrified of choking I just feel
safer doing purees and you know we
that's okay you know I mean there there
definitely are Frameworks um to show
that
there's a study called the Bliss study
which really sort of goes into very
specific things about what you can do to
reduce choking risk and when followed
correctly like Whitney said preparing
Foods in a strip soft enough to to gum
sitting up on their own upright not like
in your lap or in a car seat we don't
see any greater risk of choking with the
big red wing approach yeah and something
I think a lot of people don't really
talk about is how good the gag reflex is
for us yes a lot of people forget that
because if a baby's like gagging and
then a lot of times you know natural
concern is to freak out but they're
pretty good at let them get out of
themselves for a second well that's one
thing we always tell parents when you're
going to start solids watch some videos
and learn the difference between choking
and gagging good because a lot of
parents see a little gag and you think
the baby's choking but this is a normal
part of kind of learning how to consume
Foods yeah when they're choking you'll
know it there's no sound coming out they
may even be changing color
um and if they're gagging and you go and
pick them them up or get them on the
back you could actually cause choking
yeah and Lodge it to be worse as opposed
to their natural magnets and that's why
babies you know they naturally sort of
put things in their mouth they're all
trying to sort of learn that gag reflex
and we really want to encourage them
yeah yeah totally my daughter the other
day she's six months old now and so
she's picking things up and putting it
in her mouth like she had like a stick
and like a twig from a leaf or something
that she put in her mouth and then
gagged up her milk because that gag
reflects from her from putting the leaf
in her mouth yeah gagged it all up
anyways that was unpleasant probably TMI
but the foods that I start all of my
kids on is normally avocado I love the
healthy fats yeah and it's like soft and
easy like long strips like you said so
they could pick it up and um also sweet
potatoes and soft fruits like fruit from
our garden and bananas and papaya papaya
is a little bit harder because it's more
like mushy and you kind of have to help
them with it but things like sliced
bananas and stuff like that do you guys
do much fruit to start those are all
great Foods yeah I think iron is the
thing you need most nutritionally but
really because this is this window of
opportunity for flavor acceptance we
want you doing everything you know we
want you trying a new food every day
yeah the old advice that you had to do
one food every three to five days yeah
um it's it actually just doesn't really
make sense it's not necessary and it
good or practical and it could also
inhibit
um this ability to have exposure to a
wide variety of foods pretty quickly so
yeah fruits vegetables all of the foods
your family eats if you can find a way
to prepare them in a baby safe form
um
steamed broccoli yes in our book The
plant-based baby and toddler we have a
whole page two pages showing you all the
different ways you can cut and prepare
different foods to serve to babies oh
it's perfect for that Palmer grasp and
it's all the fruits and vegetables and
tofu and bean patties that's perfect
yeah no I'm just gonna say that they're
really two purposes
of solid introduction before age one is
to really ensure adequate iron intake
and then also promote adventurous eating
yeah you know this is as as most parents
know especially if you have already
entered into the toddler preschool and
Beyond years your baby loves food it's
sort of that honeymoon period uh when
you first start solids they start to you
know usually accept a lot of different
flavors and we really want to sort of
capture that and so the more variety the
more you know don't be afraid of spice
we don't want to obviously put like
cayenne pepper uh on our baby's food but
yeah get crazy add Ginger I did a ton of
like Curry stuff you know really just to
expose them to flavor early on it
doesn't only have to be sort of like
single single note Foods you know if I
was making like a a curry sauce I would
you know steam some tempeh and dip it in
there for my kids to try that flavor
yeah that there's there's two things to
that because for one yes you want your
kids to love the foods that you're
eating you don't have to so many
families get in this place where they're
making a separate meal for their kids
because their kids won't want to eat
what you and your husband or your
partner want to eat because you're
having Curry for dinner and the kids
don't like Curry start them young to
love all the full flavors of the healthy
whole plant foods and fresh delicious
spices that you can add to your meals if
you don't do that then they're gonna
just only want the the land crackers and
the Bland this that you're used to
feeding them then there's the other
Factor where I feel like it's Health
it's really good to show them the simple
flavors of something without spices
added to it or flavors add to it like
some plain bell pepper or plain Steen
broccoli because then they love the
flavor of just plain fruits and
vegetables if we're always having to add
you gotta add this to it and this and
this to make it make them like it then
that kind of affects their palate too
yeah so it's interesting well and that's
one of the reasons that the um the
recommendation is to avoid sugar and
salt before the age of one yeah
um is because for one of the reasons is
because of building these these whatever
profile else yeah we don't want them to
preferentially prefer foods with these
yeah totally I want to go back to
breastfeeding just a little bit because
I know we got ahead of ourselves um what
about those who who are in a situation
where they aren't able to breastfeed
what do you recommend yeah so if you're
if you're unable to breastfeed or if you
choose not to breastfeed we would
recommend uh considering uh donor milk
or formula those are really the only two
appropriate options as a substitute for
breastfeeding yourself any claims that a
homemade formula is safe is untrue we
would also really want to stay away from
any type of milk alternative so like an
almond milk or coconut milk or even like
a soy milk or a plain cow's milk none of
those are appropriate or safe under one
perfect so can you explain a little bit
further why a homemade formula would not
be okay because sometimes that can you
know go around the internet that oh yeah
just make your own formula but that can
lead to like really dangerous outcomes
yes when we hear these headlines about
Mount nourish kids we often hear that
they're being fed these homemade
formulas and the problem is you know you
think you can look at the profile of a
formula and try to replicate it yourself
but what really happens is there's often
excesses in certain micronutrients or
there's not enough of certain
micronutrients the base that people use
for these formulas is not appropriate
for babies a lot of the time I saw one
online the other day that the base was
Rock House milk and the issue with cow's
milk is that before the age of one it
can actually cause intestinal blood loss
and kids that are fed cow's milk before
the age of one have a higher risk of
type 1 diabetes they have a higher risk
of iron deficiency anemia because
they're losing blood through their
intestinal tract because of the proteins
in cow's milk
um it's it's just not safe it's very
dangerous and it's not recommended yeah
you know if you are unable to breastfeed
or choose not to
formula is not poison I think sometimes
there is such this like shame sometimes
it happens and and the reality is I
think it's 70 of all infants at some
point are fed formula uh in the first
year of life so I think we need to
obviously encourage breastfeeding and
really help to support mom and make sure
that she's able to to breastfeed but
then also if she cannot or or even
chooses not to not to make her feel like
it is this giant lesser thing or that
she's harming her baby because those are
the messages that really attract women
to want to make a homemade formula and
like Whitney said it is not only safe it
is likely very very harmful yeah it's
very predatory I think that people that
are putting these out there
um they're preying on women you're when
you're in a very vulnerable state you
want to do the best thing for your baby
and you feel so this messaging makes you
feel so shameful that you might have to
go this other other route and so
um especially if you're grieving the
loss of perhaps not being able to
breastfeed and you wanted to and then
you you are you're being you're being
preyed upon this vulnerable time and it
just is yeah we we definitely don't
encourage any of those messages and we
also think that they're they're really
harmful and shameful yeah the supporting
supportive Community is like the number
one most important part like there's no
shame or blame everyone's doing their
best that's right yeah and then at the
same time we can also learn from this
and be like how can we support mothers
better and that's actually one of the
reasons why I worked with a lactation
consultant to create the tips for
successful breastfeeding ebook that I
made and in that book and I share a lot
on my platforms anybody who knows me for
any amount of time probably knows how
much I love donor milk and I'm always
advocating for it I'm like even showing
myself pumping in the mornings in my
videos I think I heard you say you gave
a ton of breast milk yeah actually after
each kidding not my first but second
third fourth and now fifth
um I just get in this pumping habit
around two two to four weeks depending
on the baby I start to pump every
morning and you just build build up a
natural Supply to have an extra five to
seven ounces every morning and there's a
lot of tips for that and yeah that's in
my ebook as well it's really affordable
and for those of you who are listening
who can't afford it just email me
through my website and we'll give it to
you because I'm just so passionate about
helping other women be able to give
their baby breast milk and if they are
in a situation where they can't
breastfeed to be able to get that from a
community like a supportive Community we
just need more of that there is some of
it but we need more of it and being able
to donate to you know another family who
needs it for their baby has been just so
like rewarding even for myself it's just
fulfilling to be able to help someone
else because I would love if somebody
could help me in that way and I've been
able to donate thousands of ounces of
breast milk it's amazing it really comes
down to like different simple tips like
the things you were talking about in the
beginning of eating enough calories
right staying lower stressed about it
which we talked a little bit about just
like lowing their stuff in your life
accepting help being willing to ask for
help needing enough calories and
hydration that too and then there's the
Practical tips on like how to be able to
maximize your pumping sessions because
power pumping yeah because pumping is
not as effective as actual nursing like
the baby sucking is more effective at
drawing out milk than the pump so you
have to like navigate certain tips and
that goes to pumping first thing in the
morning and actually that sometimes I'll
sorry I'm going on I'm going on a rant
here this is helpful stuff yeah because
the pumping stuff is a passion of mine
because
um sometimes I'll get a mother who comes
and says oh yeah I could use some donor
breast milk and then but I really get
her story first because I'm like well
it's not that I don't want to give it to
you but what's going on yeah what's
going on because if I give it to you now
that actually might lower your breast
milk supply because once you start
supplementing with something else that
is actually what lowers your supply
because then your baby it's the supply
and demand relationship so when your
baby is suckling on you that signals to
your body to produce more milk and so
when you start supplementing it's just a
very delicate thing so you want to
figure make sure you're in the exact
situation and some of it might just be
someone says well I'm getting no milk
out when I pump and so I feel like I
need it but then we just need some tips
to help you maximize your pumping
session are you eating enough are you
doing that like the certain time of day
that helps you get the most so a lot of
people or women they wake up and they're
like oh I gotta feed my baby first
before I pump because I don't want the
baby to not get the milk but really you
should pump before you feed your baby
because it's not as effective again as
the baby will get the rest out and
there's there's milk in there like mass
mass majority of the time like there is
milk if you're doing these things right
and you're you're like educated and
understanding like what you need to do
to have the proper amount of breast milk
because contrary to popular belief like
the mass majority of women should be
able to breastfeed if given the right
education and support well and support I
mean we we really don't support women
um you know yeah they have to be most
the time uh you know you're going back
to work at six weeks uh postpartum which
you know I feel like is really the time
when you're even starting to get your
groove especially if you're a new Mama
on feeding and sleeping and and then all
of a sudden have to go back to you know
a demanding job and and figuring out you
know pumping I mean especially for
occupations where it's really hard to
take scheduled breaks if you're a
teacher if you're a nurse if you're you
know working sort of on behalf of
someone else to say oh I have to go take
a 15 minute pump break
there's a lot of considerations you know
and I and I think that unfortunately we
we don't prioritize how important
breastfeeding is sort of as a society
absolutely I mean I could definitely
test that I was working at a restaurant
as a waiter after my first three months
after I gave birth in California at the
time I was in California and the law is
technically they're supposed to have a
breastfeeding room yeah you know for
every bathroom yeah but that did not
happen at the restaurant I was at I was
you know just a standard I was working
at PF Chang's you guys know that
restaurant yeah so I needed to pump and
you also don't get breaks as a waitress
right unless it's over six hours and so
I had to like speak with my male manager
and be like look I really need a pump my
breast milk so he had he said I could
pump in his office and he would have to
go and get all the keys from like the
top chef the head chef oh my God and the
whole restaurant has to know about
what's going on we had to know that
Ellen Fisher was about to pump and so he
had to get all that and then on top of
it there was like a camera in the office
and so I had to like turn it the other
way I mean the camera thing like they
had to have it because that's where the
money is and stuff I don't think it was
perfect sure yeah they're not but like
they were just doing what they had to do
but I'm like trying to turn in the
corner it definitely was not ideal it
was too hard yeah if I wasn't super
committed I could have easily even the
amount of times I've had to pump in a in
a restroom stall is like incredible yeah
or hand expressing yeah definitely had
moments expressing like just milk into
the toilet because I had nowhere to put
it I was on the go and I'm completely
and like you said like the support we
really need more support in the
community and that's part of the reason
why I'm passionate about encouraging
other women if they're in a place to do
so they feel secure in their life they
feel inspired by the by this topic like
to consider pumping extra milk to donate
because that's another way that can help
support women to be a different world
yeah if everyone could produce milk was
doing that yeah and and not only that
but also encouraging women to be able to
make more breast milk or to be able to
feel comfortable well that's where again
the education and then the proper
diagnosis if you are having problems
um not immediately jumping on either
assuming that you you can't produce or
um jumping on non-evidence-based options
you know just like taking a bunch of
galacticogs and not worrying about like
maybe there's a mechanical issue so yeah
yeah totally like the one of the women
who had come to me and I explained her
the tips okay this is how you get
maximum pumping out and then like two
weeks later she comes back she's like
you're right I didn't need any of your
milk I just learned how to popcorn now I
got enough pumping milk and now I'm fine
because she had to go to a job and so
like that yeah yeah anyways that could
be an entire episode yeah I know I'm
like have you done an episode on this
you should
I was like yeah
it's so so important yeah okay let's go
back to baby okay toddler solid foods I
think we covered the breastfeeding
pretty well
um what is Flavor training what are your
thoughts on keeping kids food separate
to what the parents are eating we talked
a little bit about that but what does
flavor training mean okay so flavor
training is kind of this new idea
um it it refers to we've talked about
the window of opportunity about for
flavor acceptance and really there's
some research showing that there is a
window of opportunity from four to six
months which is before the age that most
health organizations actually recommend
starting solids both The Who and the
American Academy of Pediatrics
recommends starting solids closer to six
months they have kind of a range but
definitely closer to six months however
we know that this window of opportunity
for flavor acceptance but begins around
four months so this idea of flavor
training is that if you could give baby
little tastes of different flavors prior
to actually starting food consumption
you might be able to start programming
their palette to prefer specific flavors
and this is specifically about bitter
flavors those found in vegetables and
that's interesting so even like before
you're starting yeah just little taste
yes for nourishment yeah you may not
have been asking it in that regard but
the phrase flavor training is starting
to come out as this new thing that
parents could should be doing yeah
babies innately have a preference for
for sweetness and innately dislike
bitter flavors and this is an
evolutionary protective mechanism
because back in the day babies are going
around on the floor picking up um plants
that could potentially be poisonous yeah
and those were often the ones that were
more bitter so they we wanted baby to
kind of dislike bitter we wanted right
Evolution yeah you need to just like
bitter flavors
um for safety and so it does actually it
requires repeated exposure it's a
learned thing to to learn to like these
bitter flavors and vegetables so
flavor training is this idea that if we
can expose them early
um but we can't give them solid foods
because we don't really want them eating
solid food still six months the whole
problem is there's not really an easy
way to do that so you could give baby a
lick of different
um like some pureed carrots or some
pureed broccoli but
if you're advocating the way we are for
eating Family Foods or baby lead we need
you don't just have these non-salted
um puree soft purees to literally just
give baby a lick of to kind of train
their palate so it's kind of this
interesting idea but I don't really know
about the practicality at a practicality
of it not specifically this type of
flavor trading but if we're talking
about just learning to like these Foods
going forwards once you do start eating
solid foods at six months there's plenty
of ways to start training a baby's
palette and that's really just providing
this wide variety of flavors early and
often some of the literature shows that
it could take anywhere from about 8 to
15 times before a baby will even try a
new food that they see or put it in
their mouth let alone actually like it
and start eating it on a regular basis
so something we like to rent my parents
is just because your baby rejects a
certain food don't give up totally
that's how you immediately end any
opportunity or of them ever learning to
like it yeah you just keep offering
offering it over and over again and even
foods that they might have liked maybe
your baby was eating broccoli and
carrots and then around
um one or two which is the age when
picky eating typically sets in and can
also last till about age six that's the
average window if they start to reject
these foods and dislike things that they
used to like still keep offering them it
can take years yeah before they'll come
around again but if you never give them
that opportunity to come around again
because you just never put it on their
plate
um yeah it's never going to happen I can
definitely ask that my mom growing up
like we even though we had a lot of you
know a wide type lots of types of foods
that we were eating both healthy and not
as healthy foods we always had
vegetables all the time it was just
always on the plates and we'd be like oh
we don't like cilantro
but she kept us okay but she kept adding
to certain things and here it is if you
want it and then eventually we're like
oh we do like salon yeah that's great
just that kind of thing that you
experience that you're growing up and I
also feel like it's so easy as a parent
to be like well yeah why am I going to
make food that I know my kid might not
like and I think that tends to be such a
sort of common uh barrier but the
reality is is that kids are kids are
picky there is you know food neophobia
where they might not be not wanting to
try new food
um and so if we sort of stop it and
don't give it then we're really not
giving our kids the opportunity to be
adventurous eaters yeah and I just play
pickup mom like all right whenever you
don't need them yeah
serve foods that you don't even yeah
yeah and just keep exposing your child
it's we're talking about foods that are
common for the family should be things
that you continue to to provide them and
Alex and I have seen the benefits this
of this in our own house
um my son was who's the older one he's
uh almost five now he was kind of picky
from the start he there was no window of
magical eating where he would try a lot
of foods from 6 to 12 months kid is
different every kid is different and I
did all the things
um but he was a little bit less picky as
a baby
um but then he pretty much would never
really eat vegetables and I just kept
putting this is a recent success so uh I
think every day for school for the past
like two years I put carrot sticks in
his lunchbox and just about a month ago
and I put it on his plate at dinner when
it makes sense and I look over and he's
eating a carrot stick yeah you're like
instead of a burrito his like absolute
favorite food I was like not only are
you actually eating this thing that you
haven't ate for four years but you're
eating it instead of this other thing on
your plate that you love so
says yes totally it works that's a
really good encouragement yeah I think
and some kids are going to love
vegetables just from the get-go yeah
my yeah something on asparagus over at
dinner and I'm like even adults don't
like asparagus went through this phase
where he just only wanted broccoli like
that's it like steamed broccoli that's
it nothing else we're like you don't
want the sweet potato you don't want the
avocado nope just the broccoli that's
all he wanted was steamed broccoli we're
like okay well you've got to eat
something oh it doesn't eat broccoli but
it does remind me back to what you're
saying about babies at what age they're
eating more solid foods and it's
interesting I feel like this guideline
or this timeline that's like oh baby
should be eating this much solid food by
this date actually none of my kids have
eaten very much solid foods till they
were like 12 to 14 months and it was
pretty much all breast milk and
everything else was just play like
between the six seven or eight month
Mark when they start foods and then like
to a year to 12 to 14 months they're
like picking it up and barely playing
with it and barely touching like barely
getting much in their mouth but it's
just like playing and then once they hit
like that 12 14 months that's when
they're like oh all of a sudden they're
like eating good amounts of it where
it's like replacing breastfeeding
sessions yeah but it sounds like a lot
of a lot of people it can be different
whether eating a lot more a lot younger
and I think it's important to remind
people that what we think they're eating
or what they're supposed to eat is a lot
different from what they actually are
eating you know especially when you're
doing baby lead when you're like oh my
God they didn't eat anything yeah yeah
but they actually might be getting more
in than you think they are true I mean I
I joke all the time my kids loved eating
from them from the very beginning and
had you know ravenous appetites and then
you know yeah things things change I
think also to point out too that a lot
of parents will talk about is like
after they turn one sort of the opposite
sometimes happens where suddenly
appetite decreases because growth slows
down and parents feel like oh I now have
to like force my kid to eat more and
it's like you know kids are really good
about understanding how much food they
need and there there are times of growth
and of where they're going to eat more
food and there are times of less growth
where they're not going to be as hungry
you definitely don't want to shame or
push and make it this like you've got to
eat type thing like just trust in your
child's intuition and their body the way
that you do for your body that you're
not going to force yourself to eat when
you don't want to eat yeah and that's
something we're really big on when it
comes to feeding kids is sort of this
this trusting relationship you know I
think sometimes there can be such a like
you know I'm the parent I know I'm gonna
do this and and I think really to have a
successful maybe optimal feeding
relationship it's also about trusting
your kids and really trusting them to
know how much you know food they need
when they're hungry when they're full
what kind of foods they like um and
letting them sort of have that autonomy
when it comes to food Choice great okay
so I have kind of one more round about
type question but might take a little
bit time to get into
um what does the science say about the
health of feeding kids predominantly
plant-based so there's not a ton of
literature on the long-term outcomes of
plant-based diets for kids but what we
do have is is very positive and it shows
that plant-based dietary patterns when
uh appropriately planned as all dietary
patterns should be are not only safe but
likely beneficial specifically for
reducing potential chronic disease
diseases later in life and that is a
position that's supported by the um the
Academy of nutrition dietetics the
Canada health and many other health
associations globally yeah one one thing
we do see too is that plant-based kids
tend to have higher intakes of fruits
they don't have higher intakes of
vegetables higher intakes of whole
grains and they tend to have lower
intakes of things like candy and cake
and the other one sugar sweet beverages
fast food so they so overall they just
tend to have healthier dietary patterns
and you know as Whitney said too we we
don't necessarily we do have some data
so we have the more recent beachy
studies
um that show that plant-based kids tend
to have higher intakes of many nutrients
there are some things that we want to
ensure are really well planned in the
diet especially things like calcium for
adequate growth
um most of the the kids at the beachy
study were supplemented with vitamin D
and b12 so those levels were optimal but
I think that one of the biggest benefits
in starting your kids eating this way is
they're just setting them up for life
and and we're really sort of from a very
very beginning stage setting the the
course or setting the table if you will
for what is sort of the the optimal food
culture and really introducing them to
these foods that we know are really
optimal when it comes to reducing
chronic disease risk and I think that is
one of the biggest gifts and the biggest
benefits in choosing a plant predominant
or even a plant exclusive diet yeah it's
kind of what we were talking about
earlier when we're talking about beef
we're like we don't have any studies
showing that beef in babies is bad but
we do know that consuming a lot of beef
later in life is associated with poor
outcomes
um therefore we can assume that if
you're programming your child at this
early age to prefer these foods and they
continue to eat those Foods later in
life then we're going to see the same
Health outcomes that we see for adults
who eat these Foods so the same thing
can be said for a plant-based diet we
are setting our kids up to enjoy foods
that are rich in fiber vitamin C vitamin
A all of these things that are
associated with good health and likely
the same benefits that uh plant-based
dieters and adulthood
um that we see in studies of plant
plant-based adults will hopefully be the
same for children too as they age and
continue to eat these foods and the
studies talk about this there's a lot
more literature on adults in the
benefits of planting based diets I'm
sure you've covered them in other
episodes but the the studies we do have
too when it comes to some of these
cardio metabolic risk factors in in kids
you know we we do see that plant-based
kids have lower levels of cholesterol
they do have lower blood pressure
um you know so so we do know that even
at an early age there it is sort of this
optimal dietary pattern and lower rates
of obesity that's right you know we
don't we don't we don't talk too much
about sort of the the
weight uh in in childhood just because
there's so many factors uh that play
into it but that definitely is an
additional benefit to consider
plant-based kids on average tend to have
lower bmis and optimal bienna is not
like too low yes yes yeah yeah well and
again the Vichy studies show that they
had vegans and vegetarians had similar
growth to omnivores which is a common
concern I think for a lot of people yeah
we hear a lot of questions about like
you know height and you know stunted
growth and that's just not what the the
research shows you know especially the
Avicii studies they had normal height
with uh normal BMI that definitely
hasn't been my experience either all of
my kids are above average I was gonna
say if we need another anecdote I just
saw your kids at lunch and they're all
Giants
yeah well that's also because my husband
is very tall
okay I think we're gonna they're gonna
end it here we have been talking a lot I
know I love it you're so natural this is
so fun it's like a conversation yes
thank you so much for being here this is
so great thank you thank you everyone
for being here thank you all right bye
[Music]